hey everyone this is sarah with
registerednessrn.com and in this video i
want to demonstrate
how to assess the heart rate in an
infant
and of course perform hand hygiene
before beginning
to count the heart rate you want to make
sure that you're using the appropriate
size diaphragm and bell and we have an
infant here so we're using an infant
size
and for an infant who is less than a
month a normal heart rate
is about 100 to 190 beats per minute and
this can vary if the infant is
crying or if they're sleeping now if the
infant is over
one month that heart rate goes down a
little bit the normal ranges it's about
90 to 180 beats per minute
so to count the heart rate what we're
going to do is we're going to use the
apical pulse we're not going to use the
radial pulse like how we do
in adults so to find the apical pulse
what you want to do is you want to find
the fourth intercostal space now on an
adult remember it was the fifth
intercostal space at the midclavicular
line but for an infant it's at the
fourth intercostal space lateral to the
midclavicular line
so you want to find the clavicle and
then we have the breastbone
and we're going to go down and we're
going to fill in between those little
ribs
and we're going to go to the fourth
space so there's one
two three four and then we're going to
just go lateral to the midclavicular
line
so we're going to go about right here
and this is about where the apical pulse
is on our infant
and we're going to place our stethoscope
there and we're going to listen
for one full minute now an infant's
heart rate
um can have sinus arrhythmia where it's
irregular
because their heart rate is can be
affected with the respirations where
their heart rate will actually speed
up and slow down with respiration so
that's where you want to count for one
full minute now counting an infant's
heart rate can be difficult because it
is fast and one thing that i have found
that definitely helps me
is i find that heart rate and then
i like tap my finger along with that
heart rate and count and
our infant's heart rate here is about
142.
okay so that wraps up this video on how
to assess the heart rate in an infant
and be sure to check out the other
videos in this pediatrics series